we have Colonel Oliver North Colonel you
alerted me before we came on the air I
made some phone calls top sources in
Israel have confirmed that multiple
rockets were fired at Israel
within the last couple of hours in
Israel has in fact they were fired from
Syria Israel has responded no Israelis
were injured though in the attack
against them this having to do with
Israel's previously military attacks
against Syria in recent weeks nothing to
do with the Iranian deal I was told at a
very high level yeah well look never
believed in Iranian because if their
lips are moving they're lying but let me
just a little bit more about that story
then we talked about some other stuff 20
missiles fired from a Syrian base they
are Iranian missiles and those are the
kinds that they're also trying to
transition to Lebanon to give to
Hezbollah the Israeli Air Force is
responding at least when they when you
and I first talked about this about 20
minutes ago they were responding to it
it's interestingly enough such on the
same base from which I went into Syria
with the IDF back in January I think
we've got some footage of that I was on
the air with Fox News we were allowed in
fact encouraged by an Israeli defense
official to go into into Syria where the
Israelis have built a military hospital
inside Syria to help I want to make sure
the video we're showing our audience
that's the exact location that was fired
at today when nobody in Israel was hurt
but Israel's responded to just and it
was fired or we believe Iranian missiles
from Syria yes that is exactly the
report I received from a very senior
Israeli defense official he's the man
who went with me not this guy it's
showing on the screen I want to be very
clear about that
but the colonel who called me is a dear
friend and he knows what he's talking
about he knows all about the Iranian
threats to Israel coming out of Syria he
was forecasting it the base that we went
in from is the one that was attacked
today colonel I also confirmed her from
a high-ranking government source within
Israel so everything that you would you
had told me about about a half-hour ago
you know a thing or two about the
release of hostages well what is amazing
here is the rapid turnaround of
America sends a Strikeforce the
president demeans little rocket man all
over the place sanctions are put in
place and alliance with China takes
place this had not happened the the
North Korean dictator crossing the DMZ
now talking about denuclearization of
the entire peninsula by accident this
happened peace or strength
absolutely and and what what has
happened here Shawn is being rejected by
the far left because one you're
absolutely right the deep state cannot
stand the prospect of this president
being reelected they're going to do
everything they can to undermine it and
these are the kinds of propaganda this
is what this is is propaganda it's lies
about the president that are being used
to dissuade the American people from
supporting them and of course a lot
depends on this upcoming election in
November real quick we're also seeing
the same thing happening with the NRA
there's no doubt about it that's why I'm
that's why as painful as it has been
because you and I've been doing war
broadcasts since I joined this network
17 years ago and and here we are talking
about another attack on an ally by the
Iranians from a foreign country called
Syria III look at what I'm doing good
joining the NRA is there as their
president as a sad thing for me because
I can't I can't come on everyday with
you like we used to do but the fact is
the same thing that's happening this
president is happening to the NRA right
now it is a massive left-wing attack on
a great institution for civil liberties
they're lying about me every day media's
vetting me more than they vetted Obama I
understand I get it listen fine God will
simplify safe home my friend and I will
tell you this we're praying for those
those three hostages coming home